La Toscane,
une des régions les plus visitées d'Italie.
Ses paysages somptueux attirent
chaque année 10 millions de touristes.
Au coeur de la Toscane,
Sienne, la ville aux 17 quartiers.
Chaque année depuis des siècles,
sur la piazza Del Campo,
ses quartiers s'affrontent
dans une course de chevaux effrénée.
Cette course, le Palio, est ici une véritable institution.
Chaque Siennois descend dans la rue pour défendre son cheval, son quartier et son emblème.
Cet après-midi, c'est la Prima Prova, le 1er entraînement des chevaux sur la piste.
Un moment crucial
pour tester les capacités du cheval.
Depuis 4 siècles, les règles du Palio sont les mêmes.
C'est simple, il n'y en a pas.
La course est d'une grande intensité,
et elle est surtout très dangereuse.
Tous les coups sont permis,
et même à l'entraînement, les chutes sont fréquentes.
Ce soir, le 1er cheval qui tombe est celui de l'Oca,
le quartier de l'Oie.
Et quelques minutes plus tard, c'est celui
de la Chiocciola, le quartier de l'Escargot.
Une chute très impressionnante
qui provoque la stupeur.
Sitôt la course terminée, le jockey est évacué.
Gravement blessé,
il ne pourra pas participer à la course.
Les supporteurs de l'Escargot se précipitent sur la piste pour aller aux nouvelles du jockey.
Pour l'Escargot, le Palio est terminé.
Par contre, le jockey du quartier de l'Oie
a eu plus de chance.
Il s'en tire indemne.